and here is
[Music]
making the start for the rangers this
will be a second start 16 innings
13 strikeouts five walks at 3.380 r8
we haven't seen him but he is a veteran
14 years he pitched to the korean league
and he signed a minor league deal with
the rangers and was called up in april
this year we'll bring up luke
and a ground ball third base that could
be too select with the turn
in time double play five four three
around the horn
and young gets that ground ball when he
needed it sometimes it takes a little
while to get your feet under you
facing that first battery mayhew but
gets a nice ground ball here
culverson to solac to low
two outs very quickly today is uh i
guess mystery bobblehead night you could
receive
a bobble head from any of the years and
some people got corey kluber's bobble
head
corey kluber ninth game three and two
three point four eight
about a strikeout per inning last four
starts he's been really good 4-0
2.39 era and changed things up
using his change up much more and in
this four game span
hitters are three for 23 off his
changeup
and next team that's almost a laugh out
loud i mean he threw
one inning strike three
solo down looking low at 261
seven homers 26 rbis pitch
is swung on and lined right to first on
a hop
voigt goes to the bag and that will end
the inning
so klubert has a one two three here's
the choo choo
coming to the right hand hitting lamar
and the pitch is hit on the ground to
short
and the throw to first is in time from
kinder philippa
oh ryan lamarr has pulled up lame
it's just amazing it's amazing they're
young players in great
shape and they can't run to first base
and he he's pulled a hamstring
and this is ryan lamar's shot to prove
that he belongs in the major leagues
he's a great outfielder
32 years old he had not played the big
league since 2019 gets an opportunity
there's playing time out there for him
and you get hurt this way aubergine with
three home runs 11
runs batted in the 3-0 inside so there's
the first texas base runner
culberson on a walk now here's the 1-1
to calhoun and the pitch is
hit high in the year to shallow right le
mayhew is out
he calls catches and that will end the
inning no runs no hits one left uber has
been pretty tough so far he's only
allowed one ranger to reach that was
culberson
on the walk last inning two strike pitch
and then the swing of the miss and he
got him with three straight sliders
no run away on the strikeout to solo and
that will bring up
nate lowe fly ball deep right field
wade is back he has room and he puts it
right now here's the payoff
swung on hit in the air to center field
gardner back makes the catch
and that ends the inning another one two
three
kluber has not allowed a hit through
four
run that lead off walk see if he can get
another ground ball
and turn it into a double play and duhar
last time accommodated
ground ball third base culverson to
second solak onto first
there's another double play five to four
to three
and the bases are empty it's a third
double play tonight
we saw one five four three earlier but
we repeats it again right here
culverson to solac to low see if they
can
figure something out here with corey
kluber might enter
and two-time cy young award winner has
been
spot on tonight strike three
gallow down looking kluber has struck
out six he has walked one
two two half swing did he go he did
bill miller rang him up and they were
two-way and that's strikeout number
seven now for kluber
you see davis's first move is to open up
no
chance to cover that slider well two
hours and here is
isaiah kainer one-on-one
there's a weak ground ball in the third
charged by urshela
his throw in time one two three inning
kluber has not allowed a hit
through five to the sixth we go nothing
nothing so the yankees have a lead off
base runner for the fourth time in six
innings
each of the first three resulted in the
runner wiped out in a double play
the pitcher wade is swung on and lying
toward the gap and right center field
there is a base hit that ball will go
all the way to the wall
picked up by garcia he fires it in the
throw home
is not in time higgy scores from first
base
on a triple by tyler wade and the
yankees take a one-nothing lead
and he went down and got that pitch and
higashiyoka faster than you know fast
for a catcher
he just kept going around there and of
course tyler wade you knew that
he was he was in third before kashioka
was home
and now the rangers bring the infield in
with lemayo at the plate
here comes the 2-0 to le mayhew
and he swings and lifts a high fly to
left that should get the run in
on the run toward the line as calhoun
makes the catch
and wade comes easily home and the
yankees take a two nothing lead
on the sac fly and rbi by dj lemayo
not many hard hit balls if any with two
outs here comes
willy calhoun the pitch hit on the
ground to gleber torres on the first
base side of second he throws out
calhoun
clay goes 6-3 and corey kluber has a no
hitter through six all right so clover
no hits through
six innings but again another longer
wait between innings for him
and the pitch swing and a miss pitch out
of the strike zone
solac down on strikes that was not a
strike when it left his hand
it started below the knees and ended up
on the ground and the count two and two
so klibra battles back yankees have a
two-nothing lead and kluber's pitching a
no-hitter
swung on hit on the ground to short
gleber throws to first
and that ends the inning and corey
kluber
has a no-hitter through seven last time
the yankees had a no-hit bid through
seven innings it was phil hughes
in 2010 at oakland he has nine
strikeouts on the night
grounded softly to first luke voigt
steps on the bag one away here in the
eighth
here's chris davis he's over two
grounded to second and struck out
line drive and caught on one hop by
urschela
across the diamond they get davis two
away here in the eighth
hit hard but the dependable geo with
that great glove
so now kluber is four outs away and
kluber deals swung on
and driven to deep right field there is
wade for the catch and kluber has gone
through
eight with a no hitter can you imagine
what he's thinking of
as we see him walk off the mound toward
the yankee dugout
and the cory clover story is an amazing
one having pits just one inning
last year signing as a free agent with
the yankees for one year 11 million
dollars the raise and the red sox
pursued him as well he's a two-time sai
young award winner
on one hop to le mayhew two more outs to
go
for the no hitter for corey kluger one
two
to the lefty hitter and the pitch is
lined to right field
on the run as wade he makes the catch
near the line
and there are two outs and corey kluger
is one out away and here is left-hand
hitting willie calhoun
the last player to stand between corey
kluber
and a no-hitter ground ball
to cleaver torres and that'll do it a
no-hitter
for corey kluber on a wednesday night in
texas
kluber becomes part of forever corey
kluber
came within one man of a perfect game he
pitches a no-hitter and the yankees are
delirious on the field
celebrating with corey kluber in the
middle